we're here in exercise brought to you by
justine
we will start on position one
take it away justine
that is called the flying flamingo
proceeded by the right leg kick
squat
thrust
a
to left side kick
to the flying flamingo
to the knee the bent knee
reactor
now we slow down
take a deep breath
and
proceed
remember kids
don't do this for too
long or you will cramp and die
but remember
justine is an expert
and not everyone should try this
at home
oh my gosh
it is the flying domingo
it's been three years since we last saw
this in the 1999 olympics
and
no she she's going for a second time
and this could not be true good gosh
she is
doing it again
the audience does not know what to say
but
just such a nice
this will go down
as a moment in history for all gopetters
on planet earth